joe biden's entire career in politics
has been a huge gift to the chinese
communist party
20 years ago biden voted to give most
favored nation status to china which
paved the way
for its entrance into the wto and then
the subsequent destruction of millions
of american manufacturing jobs
now republicans voted for that too and
we've widely criticized them
but it's a decision biden defends to
this day and yet somehow his
administration wants you to believe
that they're going to be able to keep
the ccp in check
here's newly minted secretary of state
tony blanken in an interview with
nbc news just earlier today china poses
the most significant challenge to us of
any other country but
it's a complicated one there are
adversarial aspects to the relationship
and there's still some cooperative ones
too the challenge posed by china
is as much about some of our own
self-inflicted weaknesses as it is about
china's emerging strength
self-inflicted weaknesses you mean like
hinging our china strategy on unreliable
european nations
my next guest knows better than anyone
else the perils we face
from a growing and more powerful china
joining me now is former secretary of
state it kills me to say former
and distinguished fellow at the hudson
institute mike pompeo secretary pompeo
um first of all you have the honor
i understand of being on the china
blacklist is that true
a number of my friends are and i'm
jealous that i'm not on the list i know
you're upset about that
novak no vacation in shanghai this year
laura
oh my goodness well um let's talk about
what lincoln said there he acknowledges
that china
is an adversary or is a competitor
but that it's complex your reaction to
his posture
well laura the recognition of it as an
adversary is a good step forward that's
basically progress from where the obama
administration was for eight years and
frankly to your point earlier
it's progress from where both
republicans democrats have been for the
last
30 40 years so that's real progress the
trump administration
turned the titan we said enough to
protect american jobs president trump
said we're not going to have the chinese
dumping product here so we put tariffs
on them
all the things that recognize the threat
from the chinese communist party right
where they were
spying in our facility in houston we
closed it we took real actions and
i hope this administration will do the
same thing the track record from the
eight years prior to that is not good
it was an appeasement strategy and when
i hear people talk about places we can
cooperate
i dealt with these folks i dealt with
the senior leadership i was in meetings
with general secretary xi jinping
his view of the places we cooperate are
only those places they can dominate
and inflict real costs on ordinary
american citizens
well here's what blinken said about
holding china accountable on covet
secretary pompeo referred to the
coronavirus as the china virus do you
think that china needs to be held
accountable well the focus we have to
have
is both getting full understanding and
accountability
for what happened and there's an
investigation that's going on right now
but especially making sure we're putting
in place measures
to prevent a recurrence secretary pompeo
what full understanding do they need to
get we already know they tried to cover
up covet early on
yes we know a couple things one it is in
fact the china virus it's been ironic to
hear
some folks who said uh we were
xenophobic for talking about the wuhan
virus or the china virus
referring to the south african variant
or the united kingdom variant
this is a wuhan virus it started there
it may well have commenced from a
laboratory there we don't we don't know
for sure
we need that investigation to figure out
exactly where it began but we know this
we know that the chinese communist party
disappeared journalists we know that
they took
doctors and professionals who wanted to
tell the story about human to human
transmission
early on when something could have been
done that would have saved countless
lives and
billions of dollars of wealth and lots
of jobs for the american people as well
we know that the chinese communist party
covered that up they wouldn't prevent
permit that information to get out they
corrupted the world health organization
in a way that made it a
a political institution and not a
scientific one those are the things we
know
and the chinese communist party must be
held accountable for what it is that
they
did not only to the united states but to
the world secretary pompeo
explain for our viewers why the coup
in myanmar matters and how it's
connected to potential
biden weakness on china
well i think laura i think you've seen a
number of actions where the chinese
communist party is already
testing this administration in ways that
they dared not
when president trump was leading america
you've seen it on taiwan you saw it
again
in the last couple days now in myanmar
in what used to be
burma where the chinese communist party
has
made real advances and now they're
flexing their muscles and their power
they are now
intent on building a deep water port a
lot and a pipeline
inside of that country in a way that
will really give them
power over those people larger power
over the region
and much to the detriment of the united
states of america i hope that the
administration
will take real action in response to the
uh coup the military conducted
today or yesterday morning inside of
that country
how should we how much should we be
worried about
taiwan given what's happening in the
south china sea
right now as we speak our ally taiwan
in jeopardy yes so
yeah lord xi xingping is serious about
this we sold them weapon systems that
had never been sold to help them defend
themselves
we honored the commitments that we made
we demanded that the chinese communist
party do the same
it's something that's very concerning i
hope they'll continue to do the freedom
of navigation operations all the things
that demonstrate america's commitment to
the people
of taiwan need to continue to happen i
hope that's the case there has long been
a long-standing
bipartisan support for that i hope the
administration is prepared to continue
down that path
finally is europe going to be uh biden's
strong ally and
and taking a tough stance against china
is that what you're seeing coming out of
your old pal angela merkel
no it's it's unlikely to happen i saw
the remarks that chancellor merkel made
it's really unfortunate
she made clear that she didn't want to
pick sides well i can assure you that
xi jinping has picked sides he's picked
the side of the east of
bad actions we know what he's doing to
the citizens of china we also know what
he's doing around the world
i don't think that chancellor merkel is
going to give up a few dollars or a few
marks or euros for the people of germany
in exchange for doing the right thing
for freedom and liberty
yeah i needed trump and pompeo out of
the way to do all that secretary pompeo
great to see you tonight thank you so
much